the song Breakaway that you wrote why
did you give that to Kelly Clarkson why
wouldn't you record that that's a really
good song it was a huge hit what was
going through your mind on that I wasn't
feeling it like sometimes that happens
um I just like wasn't feeling it for me
and Kelly
got the song we gave Kelly the song and
what do you mean we gave it to her how
do you do that well there's I was asked
if Kelly could have the song and I was
like sure and then um had you recorded a
sort of a demo track of it probably like
a really rough demo
um that would sound like ass
um but like and like she did an amazing
job she has she heard a good song
Breakaway yeah does she contact you and
say I want the song or is it all done
through management through management
did you ever perform that song like if I
asked you to do some of it could you do
it now I've never done it but I should
shouldn't I or try it now can you yeah
dude I don't I don't know if I know it
do you guys know you know they don't
know it
I spread my wings and I'll learn how to
fly I'll do what I can till I touch the
sky
I don't know all the words
when you hear that and it becomes a hit
song
there it is
when you hear her have a big hit song do
you sit there and go damn it I should
have done that kind of yeah
paid because you wrote the song every
time I I hear it I'm like I actually
feel really proud and I think that it
was really cool that that I ended up you
know having a song for somebody else
writing a song for someone else um I
wrote a song Demi Lovato took it
Daydream and Leona Lewis I will be so
there's a few songs that I wrote that
other I think it would be very cool if
you were doing a concert and you did
that song I always like I like hearing a
prince do um the Sinead O'Connor song
that you know that she got from him
nothing compares to you and and it blows
me away every time he does it I think
that's a really good idea yeah you
should do that it's very cool to hear
the artist who wrote it
foreign